>> TUCR: GOOD ENING A
A FUNNY THING AUTHE LSON
CORONAVIRU NDEM.
IT'S N CAR IN THE EAREST
DAYS OTHE PANDEMIC PUBLIC HEL
FICIALS IN WASHINGTO WER
PANICKED.
AT T TI, AS YOU REMEMBER, IT
WAS NOT CLE WHAT THE MORTALITY
RATE FM TH VIRUS WOULD TUR
OUT TO BE B THAT S NOTHEIR
IN NCER
OFFICIALS INASHITON WE
TERRIFIED FOR THEMSELV.
THEYERE AFRAIDF BEING
POSE
DOLLARS TO FUN RECKLESS
EXPERIMENT IN CHINA TT IN THE
END LIKELY CREED COVID-19.
IF THAT FACT WEO BECE
PUIC IWOULD BE OVER
AND POSSIBLY INDICTEDTHEIR PROF
DONE SO TY IEDIATELY S
TOORK HIDG IT ON A COVEUP.
LASTINTE AROUP OFELLKNOWN SENTI
AND CATEGICALLY UNTE AND YBSURD
ATHE SE TIME THEY WTE
THE VIRUS DID LK ENGINEERE BYHU.
HE MAD CERIN THAT THE
SELFPPOIED FACT CHECKS WHO
NTRO THE FLOWFNFORTION
WHO DAREDHALLENGE T OFFICIALSTO
WA ALIE.
INHE FINALAYS OF E LAS
ADNISTRATION, STA DEPARTMT
FINALLY BEG A SERS
VESTATION INTO T ORIGINS
COVID.
INTO WHAT WAS HPENING AT THE
WUHA ITITUTE OF VIROLOGY.
BUTLMOST IEDIALY AFTER THE
ELTION JOEIDEN SHUT IT
WN.
SO I ALLHE LIE WEN ON
UNIMPEDEDOR A YEARND A HALF
AND WE'RE JT LEARNING NOW HOW
EP IWENT.
E INFORMED CONSENTCTION
NETWORK, AROUP THAT AOCAT
FO TRANSRENC IN VCINE HAS
JU OBTAINEDHOUSDS OF NEW
EMAILS TO AND FM TON FAUCI
SHING AMONG OTH THINGS THAT
HENEW HISWN DIRECTIVE OFTEN
HAD N BAS I SCIENCE.
FOR EXAMPLE, I FEBRUARY O LAST
YEAR FAUCI TD U IUBLICTHAT THEOO
ONE OFWO WA.EITHER A CATTROPHIC
AT'SHAT WE WERELL WRIED
OUT O IT COULD VY WELL TN
OUTO BE JT AN UNUSULY B
SEON.
>> IF ITVOLVES INTO A PDEMI
FLU IT WI BE VERY MU LE A
ALLYAD FLUEASON OR A
MODERATELY BAD PANMIC SEON.
PANDEMIC OR JUST BADFLE A
ICHNE WOULD IT TURNUT T
BE?AT LEAST ONE REPORTER AED HIM
TH IN AN EML.
HE'S MAN CLED JOHN -- T
CHF MEDICAL CORRESPONDENT AT
CBS NEWS
ON FEBRUARY 16F LASEAR HE
ASKED FAU JUST HOW DANGEUS
VID-19 WAS.
WHAT WERE THE NUMRS O IT?
ATHAT TE YOU'LL REMEMBER
TO WEARMASKS. THE PUBC NOT
WASELLING REPORTERS IWAS
FINE TO AEND POLICAL
PUBLIC GATHERIS WE OKAY
FAUCI RESPOED TOIMY OUTLININ TH
WOULD MEIM CNGE HIS MIND
AND DEMAND CKDOWNS.
HE CURRENT MORTALI OF
VID-19 ISBOUT 2%.
WEVER, THERE AEVERALOLDS
MORE CASES THAT ARE COMG TO
THE OFFICIALTTENON OF HEAH
THORIES."
IN OTHER WOS, ASYMPTOMATICR
NIMALLY SPTOMATIC
INCTIONS.
IF YOU COU THE THE CASE
TALI RATE COULD DROP TO 1
OR EVEN HALF A PCENT O LESS.
IFHAT' THE CASE, THE TS
ULDE A VY SEVER FLU SEASON.
.2 TO .4 REGAR FLUEASON IS
%.
WE'REOT SURE WHERE THIS
GOIN TO LAND.
SOT'S IERESTINGO NOTE THATTONY
DIVIDED BY CFIRMED COVID-19 MEA
CASES.
CONFIRMEDEANI PEOPLE WHO
HAVE GEO THE DOCTOR, USUALLY
DI IN A HOSPIT.
BUT THEN FAUCI STARTS TALNG
ABOUTHE INFECTION FATALITY
RATETHAT INCDES THE TOTAL
ESTIMAD AMOUNT OF COVID-19
INFECTIONS IN E COUNY,
INCLUDINGNES WIT NO SYMPTOMS.
THAT A FARORE MEANINGFUL
TRYING TO MAKE HEALT POLICY F
TH ENTE COUNY.
HOW NY PEOPLEHO HAVE THE
VIRU ARE DYINGROM IT?
WHAT I THATMBER
FROM VID? ACTUAL DEA RATE
ATHE HIGHF TH OUTBRE IN
LATE MAY THECDC' BEST
ESTIMATESF THE FATITY RATE
FOR PEOPLEITH CID-1
SYMPTOMS, JUS THE ONES WITH
SYMPTOMS, W %.
THAT EIMAT WAS CONINED IN A
PANDEMIC PLANNINGSCENARIOS.
RELEASE.D FORHOITALIT WAS N IN
JP MORGANOOKED ATHE DATND
CAMEO THE SAIL CONCSION
EFFECTIVELY ALU SEON.GHT OTHE P
AT THE WORS
T THAT'S NOT WHAT FAUCIAID
UNDERATHHEN H TTIFIED AT
A HSE I DON'T HE SIGHT
HEARING I MAR OASTYEAR.
IN M HEARING HE CLAIMEDHAT
THE COV-19 IECTI MORTALITY
RATE WAS AROD 1%HICH FAUCI
EXPLAINED MNS IS "10 TIMES
MO LETHAL THAN THE SEASONAL
FL"
THAT'S UNTR.
THAT'S A E.
IT TURNS OUT.
IT'S HD T THINK OF A MORE
MISLEADINGSE OF MBER
AGE OF 70 TNEDUT T BE NTHOF 99..
UCI KW TH.
MARCH 16,OMEONE LAID A
QUESTION F FAUCI, FOX NEWS
ANOR KED, GIVENHE RATIVE
SAFETY WHYOT QUARANTE THOSE
WHEMMUN STEMS A
COMPROMISE STA TUNED SO WE D.
IN THE NEX F WEE FCI SAID
SHUTHEOUNTRY DOWN.
NCOURAGED CLOSING SOOLS
EV THOUGH AS HE WROTE IN ONE FEA
VERY LOWATE OFINCTIO"
HE KNEW THAT BUT H PUSHED T
CLOSE SOOLS ANAY.
THENE TD EVERYONE IN THE
COUNTRY T WEA MASKS EVEN
THGH H KNEW THE DIDN'T WORK.
HE EXPINED IN ATHER
FEBRUARY EIL WRE JUST NOW
GETTIN "THE TYPAL MAS YOU
REALLY EFFECTI IN KEEPI OUT
VIRUS WHICHS SLL ENOUGH T
SS THROUGHHE MARIAL."
THOS MASKS DON WORK BUT FAU
CONTINUED TOEMAN THAT YOU
WEAR THOSE DRUGSRE MASKS.
CTINU TO DEMAND THAT THE
LODOWN CONTINUE.
WHY D HE DO THA WHE HENEW
AND WE KWOR CERTAIN NOW
BECAUSE WE N PROVE WH IT THE
EMAILS, HENEW THOSE WER NOT
REMMENTIONS GROUNDE IN
SCIENC
BU HE PUSHEDHEMYWAY.
Y?
CAN SAY FOR CEAIN.
DO KNO THE EFFEC O THESE
RECOENDATIONS WAS KD OF
MECAL MARSHAL LAW.
TH COURY WASO MISERABLENDSO OFFT
NO ONE RLLY THOUGHTO ASK
WHE DIDHIS VUS COME FR?
BU FAUCI KNE WHERE IT ME
OM.
THE ENDF THEEDER CEBRATING
MOTORIUM ONMERICAN TAXPAR
FUNDING OF GAIN OF FUNION
SEAR.
GAIN OF
FUNCTI RESEARCH.
LET MEXPLAS THIS A LITE
BECAEHENEVER THIS COMES OUT THEK
AN FOR FROM THE PRESS.
LI NIH NOWS GNG TO DO
NGEROUS REARCH.
.
AS A MTER  FACT, IT'S
EXTLYHE POSI.
SO A FRAMEWORK HASEEN NOW
TABLISHED TO GUI FDINGDECISION
CRTE TRANSFERR U ENHCED
POTENTL PANDEMIC PAOGENS.
>> TUCKER: I GOING TOPEAK
SLOWLY NOW FOR THOSE OFHO Y ARE
THEUMB PEOEN TH AUDIENCE,
WHICH IS ERYON BUT ME.
THE H IS NOT GNG TO CONDUCT
NGEROUSEXPEMENTS.
THAT WAS FAUCI'S PROSEAND, IN
FACT,T WA HALF TRUE.NIH DID N C
EXRIMES.
E NIH TONY FCI PAID FOR THE
CHINES TO CONDUCT DANGEROUS
EXPERINTS AND HEDID.
THERE IS N DEBATE ABOUT THAT
NOW.
IT HAENED
SOHAT AREHE CONSEQUCES
INGO BE?
WHATAPPE I YOU DOOMETHING
LIKE TS AND WRECKHE COUNTRY?
WILLAUCI FACE ANY
CONSEQNCES?
THHITEOUSE AWERED THAT
QUESTION TODAY.>> WELL I TNK WEO
THIS PRETTY EENSIVELY FRO
HERELET MEUST SAYN D FCI AND
THIS MANY, MANYIMES OVERHE T
LA, OVER THE COURSE OF E
ST FEW DAYS AND WE'LLET H
SPK F HIELF.
AN HE'S BEENN UNDENIABLE
AST IN OUR COUNTRY' PANDEC
RESPONSE BUTT'S OBVIOUS NOT
TH ADVANTAGEOUSOR ME TO
LITIGATE THE SSTAN OF
[LAUGHTER]1ONTHS AGO.
>> TUCKER:EID SAK FOR HIMSELF.
HE'S ALWAY GOT A PLACEN THE
WALLACE SHO WHE THEY WILL
TELLIM WHAT AREATAN HE IS.A GRE.
CAN SPEAK F HIMSELF O
MSNB
SO NOTHING IS GOI TOAPPE TO
TONYUCI.
HE WON'T EN LE HI J EV.
ASIDEN EXPLAINED DAY,E'LL
NER BE FIRED.WATCH THIS.
CAN YOU IGINENY
CIUMSTCE WHE PRESIDENT
DEN WOULDVERIRE HI
>> NO.
EAD.
>> TUCKER: YE
YES.
AND NOT OY IEEVER GOING
TOE FIRED,ELD TOCCOUNT FOR
THIS,OR